three four years ago now  streaming numbers start coming out  and  my experience walking through an airport  or being out in public  suddenly is way more intense than it  ever even was back when we were on  thursday nights every day wow  and that was the entire experience of  the book of starting the podcast was  really based on that question which was  why why  why is this why is this happening  because it is one of the biggest hits in  the history of television well now  now  more people are watching it now than any  other show in television like think  about that that's insane so you know you  still have the cover what stranger  things or you know  whatever the hit streaming show of the  moment is  more people are watching the office that  are watching those shows still